We're just checking the stream health and then we're gonna get into it!
I've absolutely forgotten everything about this game.
I need to tap my wishbone to see me.
YouTube hasn't prompted me yet to...
Oh there we go!
Sorry if I worried anyone.
The stuff is used.
Good morning!
Okay I'mma just tell you, I'mma keep it a Costco hot dog and I'll buck 50.
I didn't do anything.
There's no secrets to spell.
I've not been active.
I felt very ill after yesterday's stream and it took me so long to finally fall asleep
when I did.
I got 7 hours but the problem is I've only completed like the first level and maybe the
second one in my childhood, okay?
And this game goes for like 5 hours and so what I would normally do is watch someone
play it on like times 4 just to get a general idea of what I'm supposed to do but I didn't
have any time to watch someone else play it and we might be up shit creek when they paddle
in this game.
But I didn't realise this game is Japanese.
I don't know if that's in silly but like I've never got to any, I never got to a train
track level or none of that.
I don't remember any of it so we're doing it live, hope yeah.
So I might need just to come in my hood.
Only on Xbox.
It's called Blinks, I suppose it's like a blink in time maybe that's the play on words.
I've never heard of this game before as Japanese would never have guessed.
What from the Neko?
Oh I don't really recall much of this.
We'll do green because I'm green.
Please don't plan off your eyes folks, I won't.
I'm using a rare replay for this.
Oh you want to know a nice game developed in fact.
Instead of having to translate everything, like get everything voice acted in a different
voice, if you use a gibberish language you can universally push the game like that because
all you need to do then is a subtitle translation.
So this is a way to save money in a game dev studio.
That's why the popularity has gone up because damn they're just another cog in the machine.
I can't believe it, not this game.
We need to have Blinks.
We are back from the change of clothes.
Hello reverse.
I'm so sorry if I scared you about how long it took for me to get the weight room up.
So I finished stream and then a kidney sleep and then just everything was gone for me.
What's happening?
Why am I getting up to me?
Sorry.
Got to do a fun thing for someone.
That is an inviola right now.
See look it's Japanese!
The Tom Tom gang.
That's the evil.
That's how you know they're evil because they're called Tom Tom.
Using the streamers back on Sunday in time.
Yeah get educated, get educated, get educated.
Oh my god.
Please tell me that's the final boss and there's nothing bigger because that's scary.
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Oh he's that kawaii ne.
Oh my god Blinks found his Oshi.
Nando desu ka? Nani kore?
Danger level exceeding.
Oh no, what are we gonna do?
We must protect the other worlds.
We'll be cut off from the time factory.
Its supply of time will be forever frozen.
Run away, run away!
And Blinks said all employees stationed in the world exit immediately.
Forget it buddy.
That one human romance.
Oh Blinks a baddie.
Oh he's sending it!
He said fucking send it!
Meow!
Okay Blinks a badass though.
Oh cool.
Oh shit.
Okay right tutorial let's go.
Right I've got a cup of tea.
I'm gonna pause once we get through the reading bit.
Time sweep begins.
Defeat all the time monsters.
Right okay what do we do?
You found a time crystal.
Look for time crystals of the same colour.
Collect four crystals at least three must match.
Okay.
You got a pause.
Everything pauses except you.
Oh this is what I need for this.
Blinks!
Oh come on its first thing in the morning.
Come on, come on, come on.
Hold down bravo and select the time control you want.
When you release bravo the time control goes into action.
By the way you can have only three time controls at once in your ammo.
Three time controls at once in your ammo.
Okay.
Right I'm gonna pause champ.
I'm just gonna have my cup of tea and do a little bit of yapping.
Strongly doing yapping.
Just get to the gameplay for once.
You know what refund?
You know what?
That's true.
But how dare you?
One how dare you?
Two?
How dare you?
I don't know why but the stream is the runescape thumbnail again.
That's weird.
No its blinks for me.
Hold on.
I'm just gonna reset the thumbnail now.
It is blinks for me.
I wholeheartedly is blinks.
But I will reset it.
That's strange.
That's twice that's happened now.
There's another stream where it was like refuse into the play as the right one.
We did not finish runescape 99 cooking but we are gonna do a finishing up stream soon.
Where we tie off loose ends of games that we didn't complete or didn't finish off.
And then my YouTube frozen.
Well sorry YouTube geez.
Is this runescape?
Look they had a bit of an update.
A bit of an overhaul.
Okay I've re-changed it.
I don't know if that thumbnail worked or not.
I just noticed that it was like yes.
Merci modi's of viewer.
Made 10,000 subscribers.
Congrats on the milestone.
Merci.
I love you.
Yippee.
And then congrats to M.E.B.Zoo for 20,000 milestone.
We're so proud of you.
Yippee.
The girls are doing fantastic.
Let's go.
Ba ba ba.
Ta ta ta.
And then next.
No.
This is from my guess.
So AC is going to have a YouTube role play ASMR role play come out.
My prediction is that she will be the next 10,000 subscribed talent.
And then I'll be Azura.
And then I can release the secret artwork for the 10,000 celebration.
I was like thanks for everyone to come over.
It was a pretty penny.
It was actually, I can tell you a funny story about the artwork.
So the artist, I hadn't worked with them before.
And we got to the point where we were like we need the fourth fix.
And then we just said, can you just hand over the source file and we'll do it ourselves.
I got that, I got that back.
And it's right.
So here's the thing about art.
To hand over the source file is to hand over all the separate layers and everything in
it.
Okay.
And we got to the fourth fix.
And normally an artist will charge for that.
They'll charge extra if you want the source file.
But what happened was both the artist and like the other side of the part because I
was having to work with a concept artist to get the fixes at the time.
And we were like, we were like, look, is it okay if we can just get the source file and
I'll have our in-house concept artist fix it.
But it will still be made in your style.
There'll be absolutely nothing taken away.
And they're right here.
Just take it.
That's how, like that artist is like, you have no idea how really bad it is.
Like, I've been, because I pay in advance, which I've kind of, I've been a bit hesitant
to do with other artists now because of a few incidences.
But yeah, that was really kind of them.
But I have to admit, it's absolutely hilarious that it was like, look, mate, we're trying
our best to get the fixes, but it's not working.
So just hand us the file.
And they actually did.
They were like, here, just take it.
And then I was like, okay, that's the commission over.
Thank you.
But yes, I can't wait to show that artwork off.
But yes, Mercy and Emmy both hit a milestone last night.
Whilst I was asleep in my slumber, Gimli, Gimli was missing me.
Oh my goodness.
She was all over me like a rash.
I'm sorry.
I'm like, no, no, don't worry.
We just been cheating.
Don't you mind?
Let's just take my arm.
They're like, they've had enough.
I don't have any updates because I kind of just passed out.
I'm a bit dehydrated right now.
I know.
The clipping program, I guess T minus 40 hours for the established clipper program.
I need to write off all those fucking documents and sensitives and fucking rules of being like,
if your content turns to piss while you're with us, we have the right to just pay you
and then kick you out the program.
All that.
Oh God.
Oh God, more work.
Bleeding Hearts News, Azure's multiple organisms under the microscope for audio is ready.
And I think it's 20 minutes long.
Yeah, I believe it's 20 minutes long.
Once Blinks finishes and granted, I don't go far enough, Bleeding Hearts, your thing's
going to go up.
Reeflings, our thing is being temporarily swapped.
I am going to make a different type of meta audio, which I've already forgotten what I
was going to make, but it was a hell of a lot easier than finishing off the current script.
So I'm recording that tonight and then I'm editing it and it should go up.
And then the pregnancy should go up on YouTube.
And then I'm going to take a look at ACs because I might be able to edit ACs without much problems
at all, but I think I need Folly.
I think I need new SFX for AC because she's doing, right, close your ears if you don't
have any spoilers for the next minute.
AC's role play is like scratching your back and scratching your hair ASMR with her claws.
So I'm going to have to put on fake nails to get like skin sounds like...
Hope you got a good read.
I got something.
Let's, I think, go.
Yes, that's a lot of organisms.
It is.
There was three organisms.
So I hope you're all ready for that.
I'm a slurp my coffee.
I don't drink coffee.
Slurp my tea.
Actually, I'll tell you something really sad.
I bought coffee for my dad and his empty coffee jar was on the counter whilst I was making
the kettle, like the kettle boiled and I was like, I don't know.
I'm like, ah, shit.
Okay, that's kind of sad.
Oh boy, I love where organisms under the telescope are mentioned truly.
You sent Chipper this morning for someone that had nae sleep?
Mama, I had an idea last night.
Yes?
You were talking about doing all six girls as lowly pops for an ASMR.
Yes, I probably will.
And I think someone mentioned calling it Operation Honeypot, but instead, how about Operation
Honeypot?
Due to legal advice from my legal team, a veiler headquarters, I cannot make a comment
on how absolutely hilarious that concept is.
Thank you, tiny Spanish.
That is ridiculous.
Oh my God, that's so good.
Right.
So we were going to change the audio.
You reeflings that are on my Patreon are okay with this.
I was going to change the audio to, if you're going to groom my girls, groom them right.
If that's okay with you guys.
Yes, it's outrageous.
Oh my God, you know how we redirected into, it was like, oh God, I'm going to say it horribly wrong.
It was Kion.
It was a Kion.
I'm going to say I'm absolutely butchering her name right now.
Hold on.
Wait, what?
AC leaks veiler's 3D debuts.
You better not have.
Oh, this is, so AC sent me this, wait, hold on, hold on.
Let me pull it up.
I'm going to put the link in the chat.
AC sends me this thing, right?
And she's like, can I get it turned into a short?
I'm like, sure, I have absolutely no idea what this is.
And she starts like wetting herself like, this is what the 3D debut from veiler is going to be like.
I'm like, AC, I'm fucking sweating my arse off here.
I don't think the order releases matter.
Okay.
It was so funny.
Literally.
Am I being daft?
I think I am.
Oh, it was Keon.
I knew it was Keon.
Fucking, we redirected into Keon and then she goes like, oh, I was lurking your stream.
And I'm like, oh, blit.
Bruh.
When other VTubers lurk my streams, all they get is me either.
One, going on an absolutely schizophrenic rant about whatever's upsetting me.
Two, they get just me straight up saying that I'm r-word in any refund and site.
Three, it's the most inappropriate misconduct plausible in the VTuber community.
I'm like, what do you mean you lurk on my streams?
What do you mean?
You're making me nervous.
But I'm not going to lie, she actually kind of sold the Lombok in my corporation game.
I'm going to look at gameplay because she kind of had me.
Like, she kind of had me.
The best first impression ever.
It's pronounced Sion.
What do I say?
Sion.
Oh, that makes sense.
Sion heart.
Okay.
That makes more sense than what?
Yes, I'm still here, Xbox.
Please don't kick me off line.
I'm going to say I get to finish my thingies.
It's real fun until you hit week three.
Oh no.
Strawny playing blanks.
Yes, I'm finishing my cup of tea and then we're going to go through the tutorial
and we're going to see how far I can get in the game because as a child,
I only played the first mission over and over
and I never got any further.
My dad didn't know how to play it so I couldn't be like that.
Go ahead and hit me again.
Hold it.
Xbox.
She ain't done yet, but honestly.
Cozy lobotomy corp stream.
Xbox.
Come on.
Just play me.
Oh God.
The people is really good, but it's a big hit or miss depending on people.
You are cup of tea.
Good advice with no guff is invaluable.
Not surprised they're hanging up.
Is this game that hard?
I mean, I was like a Barbie when I played as a child, literally.
Like, I played video games before I could even read or write, basically.
So, like, it's always been in my spirit, you know?
But please remember that I only started playing video games at two years old
for the attention of guys.
I just thought you should know that.
I don't actually like video games.
Stop.
iPad.
No, I never had an iPad.
I never had.
That is a reference before anyone's like, what on earth are you going on about?
That was a reference I made in yesterday's 12 hour stream.
Good luck finding it.
I basically long story short, my sarcasm horrifically backfired.
Someone said to me, why do you play video games?
And I thought it was just the most bizarre thing.
I was like, well, everyone plays video games.
Why are you asking me in particular about why I play them?
But it was clearly like, you're a girl, why do you play them?
So then I sarcastically wrote back, I do it for male attention.
I don't actually like video games.
And the guy didn't argue and it was the end of conversation.
And I was like, shit, that backfired.
So there is a guy currently out there with a fallacy about like, no girls actually do pretend to enjoy video games for attention.
And it's all because of my sarcasm.
Womp, womp, womp.
Motherfucking womp.
Actually ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
Oh my God, Nanny has the KU100 microphone.
I just looked at her thumbnail and she's like $20,000 audio.
I'm like, yeah, damn, that's quite the commission, Nanny.
You've got quite the price per minute.
Quite the price tag per word.
That guy's name, Albert Einstein, literally.
Guys, she's a fake gamer girl, she plays with the controller.
Literally, the controller isn't even on right now, don't we talk about?
There's actually a reef one under the desk right now playing.
And yes, that reefing, literally, yeah.
Is that blinks? It is, unbelievable.
Okay, I finished my tea, I've had half a cup of water.
And the words of the coconut and Elden Ring.
Let's get to it.
Hi.
Right.
Okay, right, okay.
Oh, you found some trash.
Hold X to speak.
Okay, that looks a lot easier.
With trash, you can shoot time monsters.
By the way, you can have only five at a time.
Okay, can I do the light?
No.
Whoa.
Oh, the...
I'm bug, I'm getting blinded.
Try to pick up this garbage.
Right, I can only have five ammo in the chamber at once.
Oh, I was supposed to pause it.
And because now it's inaccessible.
I don't know what that...
Yeah, it's inaccessible.
Okay, that's fine, I can handle that.
Right, let's get full ammo.
Let's get more familiar.
Oh, God, the...
Oh, or not, let's just...
I guess I just...
Yeah, okay, that's fine.
I can hear something bouncing.
Right, how do I throw it at the camera?
The camera goes the wrong way.
It's time to pull, right trigger, or tap X to shoot.
Oh, my God!
Okay, okay.
What is this?
I don't know.
You gotta pause.
What is this?
16 tons!
16 tons of wet...
tons of shite!
Alright, X is to fire.
Wait.
Okay, I was about to be like,
wait, this is so easy.
Why did I struggle in childhood?
Right, so suck them up.
Okay, hold on, let me suck, let me suck.
I will admit visually it's a bit rough.
I don't know how to get rid of the...
What?
We have ammo, that's the main thing.
Let's open up this door.
We're getting there.
Did he just hit the griddy on that?
I think he did.
What's this?
What's that?
Oh, there's a wee enemy on the wall!
What did I do with him?
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, there's an enemy down here.
I don't know what I was supposed to do with that.
Was that like a secret?
Oh, I forgot.
It's X to fire.
Hurry to the goal gate.
Okay, I'm off.
That's the goal gate.
Let's go.
Okay, we did it!
We finished the tutorial.
Okay, game over.
Oh no!
My elite gameplay!
There's a replay!
Oh my god, that's embarrassing.
There's a replay on my...
Oh.
Oh no.
Real credit.
What game is next?
Oh no, not me trying to get in between the graphics.
Oh, he's so smiley.
He looks like Cheshire.
Okay, right.
That's not bad.
Live action replay.
Stage 2.
And then a shop.
Welcome to the shop.
Total gold shop.
Oh my god, this is so Japanese.
A time holder.
Exit.
A retry holder.
A time holder out of stock.
This succomatic.
A new fit.
Okay, thank you.
You didn't find anything.
Sorry, you couldn't find anything.
I hope you'll come again.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Your fastest time, 10 minutes.
Sir, I haven't even played this game.
Right, okay.
Right, let's do this.
Let's get to it.
Right, first we'll put...
We'll get all the ammo.
Chat is a cat.
Everybody wants to be a cat.
Because the cat's the only cat.
A noose, where is it?
What is that?
Beed.
Right, okay.
We've got pauses.
I'll take pauses.
Well, that doesn't look like a pause.
Right, let's go find some enemies.
Ooh.
I see gold.
Right, ready?
Three, two, one, bonk.
And then we'll reload.
Like, come on.
Currently, you only have three controls at once.
How do I activate that?
I don't even know.
I've forgotten...
Is it B?
It's B.
Okay, bravo to pause.
Ooh.
We've got two slows.
Wait, why did that change?
Use slow to tankroll.
Try using it to fight enemies and avoid hazards.
Ooh, yeah.
Ooh, yeah!
Wait, am I already dead in the game?
I only have one heart.
Ooh, yeah.
Piss.
Right, you had a play.
Right, you?
Piss off.
No, you.
What are you aiming at?
Blinks, please don't.
Danger, when it's...
I'm out.
Oh, I just killed myself.
I just killed myself.
I actually just killed myself.
Ooh!
Ooh, I can't see any of the enemies.
I don't know.
The controller's so bad.
Okay, hold on.
Am I safe now?
Can I just aimball at it?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, I missed.
That's okay.
Okay, I missed again.
Oh, my God, stop.
It's all coming apart.
I should have played this.
I should have played it off-stream.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, leaflings.
I'm sorry.
I should have played it off-stream.
I'm not even kidding.
How do I wallop it from here?
Okay, that was right.
Try again.
Okay, we did it.
Oh, my God, I should have played it off-stream.
Eat his heart, real.
All right.
Is there anything I can make here?
I've got two hearts.
I can just go full ammo and grab his gold again.
Oh, my God.
Oh, well.
I would like another love heart, if possible, but...
I can't see.
Blinks, please.
The camera angle.
Whoa, go the money.
Money.
This looks like a boss fight.
How did I deal with it?
Oh, the camera, please.
Camera angle.
Work with me.
What did I do?
Just threw shit at him.
Oh, shit, I'm dead?
I have no more lives.
I literally have no more lives.
Okay.
There's a guy there.
You got a renew.
Oh, it's a rewind.
Sorry.
I didn't sign up for an MLG.
Thank goodness, because this is awful.
This is not going the way...
Ooh, what are you?
You got a secret cap medal.
Collect lots of these to unlock kill stuff.
Okay.
Oh, hearts.
I need hearts.
I need all the freaking hearts I can get.
I'm not even kidding.
Please help me.
Okay.
Howdy.
Hi.
Thanks for joining.
I'm sorry that my MLG gameplay isn't that good.
You got a retry.
Okay.
A retry gives you another chance.
Okay, right.
That is what I'm needing.
I guess some stuff can be...
No one...
Oh, my God.
I really struggle to get used to this camera angle.
I need to pick up ammo.
What did I see?
Maybe our time control can fix this.
What, like right now?
And what did that do exactly?
Did I just waste that?
No, we just...
We just...
No!
Motherfucker!
Okay.
So that was your stuff.
So I don't know why you told me about that.
Don't do that again.
Where are the flowerbites considered...
Literally!
What's up here?
I need to aimbot this motherfucker.
Ah!
No!
I'm scared.
Stop being invisible!
I don't have any more ammo!
Don't think I won't run away and pick up more ammo.
You stay there.
I'm coming back to beat you up.
I need to suck up this park bench first.
You're so rude.
Time stop for real.
I guess these guys.
The greatest game of all time?
Is it?
Oh, good.
If it is, I'm doing it zero justice right now.
Like, actually zero justice.
This game, a lot easier to play in my head as a child.
The camera is killing me.
The camera goes the wrong way.
No!
Right there.
One monster.
Him?
Blinks!
You're constantly not looking at the right thing.
I don't know why he hates me.
Just say you hate me.
Right, so this is the door.
Is that door him?
I like how if you kill the monster,
I actually have a symbol on the ground to be like,
I guess war.
200 gold for this level?
That's actually like tons.
Okay, let's go.
Fun idea for a future collab.
Have you heard of Giga Bash?
It's a molecular monster fight game.
I actually haven't heard of it.
Mummy freezes time and main breaks.
That's kind of hard to gameplay.
Wait, there was a third secret I didn't see?
My fastest, I got rank D.
You know what else got rank D?
Okay, that's cute.
Now, can we do the first boss level?
Oh no, stage three, my apologies.
First ammo.
This is the main thing.
We need it every time.
We need the ammo.
Give me the ammo.
We need to be safe.
Because if I have five ammo,
then it means we can just fire away.
I like how the street things actually do try and put you in the right way.
Like if you're going the wrong way, the game's like,
hello, maybe don't do that way.
Oh, is there no secret here?
Release me!
Got that camera angle is really bothering me.
Hopefully I can get some more hearts.
Oh jeez.
Please, I'm just a cat.
I'm just a cat.
Whoa, you can ride barrels, barrel rider.
Okay, we don't, I don't know what these 10G things are about.
Right, it's giving me two stars, so I just need one star.
Almost got it.
Oh my god, the game is actually giving me positive affirmations.
Okay, thank you.
Five monsters to go.
Who or what?
How do I aim for that?
Can I like jump and shoot?
Oh my god, I can!
Blinks, what the heck?
That was so cool.
I didn't even know I could jump and aim.
I'm not going to pick anything up because I've no got, I'm assuming those guys, I'm supposed to wall it when I see them, but...
I don't know if we're doing it in time.
Great.
Blinks, can you all walk?
No way!
Okay, okay, no, hold on, sorry, I keep accidentally opening up that B now.
Much regretty, big spaghetti.
Right, you?
Oh, I missed, sorry, let's try again.
Oh!
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
Right, stop pressing B, do you understand?
Yes, I'm sorry.
Right, we're going to throw away this because we're going to pick up the hearts because I want hearts.
I haven't played it so long, I'm going to play it.
There's a blinks too!
Okay, how do I auto-lock to him?
Oh my god, I'm actually so good, I'm actually so good.
Who spawned me into this world as a gamer?
Oh my god, and I have more life.
Hold, it's clicking, it's clicking.
You got to let me warm up, okay?
It's like I'm a hot skillet on a stove right now, got to let me warm up.
That's it, this round is done, I'm just so good.
I'm actually just so good, we've already done it.
I'm officially warm, time's sweet complete, and we got out with the health.
I'm just so good at this game.
Surely I'm not going to get stuck anywhere.
Sorry, sorry Elden Ring gamers, Bloodborne gamers.
Do you guys think that's a challenge?
This is a challenge.
No secrets, but no, you didn't read that, no, no, right.
We have 500 gold, so can we do anything with this?
A retry holder, a thousand for more health.
Okay, that to me looks good to me.
We'll do a thousand for health.
Now, if we get walloped in the boss and I die and have to restart the game.
Am I playing on it?
No, this.
Why you just, I didn't, you just, what do I do?
What do I do?
I couldn't even run that far, I tried.
I didn't even give me a chance.
Fucking one pause, fucking let's relax.
Two, let me pick up some items.
Oh my God, I can't even shoot him because he's in the fucking air.
Oh my God, please.
Oh, I can't even do anything, he's in the air.
Fuck you, fuck you.
Oh shit, he's invincible.
Shit, I forget they get invincible.
Noob wasted all that ammo.
Oh God, oh God, oh God, oh God.
Just a little bit of panic at the time.
It is perfectly normal to feel panicked in a video game.
Oh my God, I can't hit anything.
What the fuck does this one do?
Slow, yeah, yeah, you better slow down.
Yeah, boom, bitch.
Yeah, get fucked.
Okay, what's that?
He needs like two more hits or something.
Okay, he's gonna do his wee thing.
I'm gonna reload.
Gimme, gimme, ammo, gimme, ammo, gimme, ammo.
Okay, get right.
I'm gonna pop you like a damn balloon.
Do you understand?
Oh my God, I'm so good.
I'm actually, oh my God, I'm so good at this game.
Oh my God, the level's already over.
Give me all the monies.
Money, money, money.
Can we get a thousand?
Oh no, it disappeared.
Oh well, it's fine.
Hold on, wait, maybe we can pick up a few more pennies.
I would like to get another health holder
for no particular reason at all.
I would like more health.
Oh my God, I thought he was putting me in another fight there.
I just got shivers.
I thought he was shoving me in another fight.
I'm like, no, don't do that.
That's rude.
Don't do that.
Right, there's no secrets in boss levels.
That's fine.
Good job, my man.
Thank you.
Maybe you can suck up the money when you're back.
Maybe that would have been faster.
Phase two?
I ain't doing a phase two.
Okay, so we've technically finished
tutorial island in this game.
We are now going to the deja vu canals.
Okay, as always, we will pick up ammo
and take it from there.
Elden Ring Who?
Dark Souls Where?
This is weird.
That's exactly what I said.
Oh, there's money.
Oh, there's enemies.
Okay, it seems to have a hidden auto lock,
especially for those monsters,
which is understand, oh, we can ride the water.
Yeah, the auto lock is like moving in,
which I'm quite, I'm happy to see that.
I think that's very, stop.
Yeah, let me just slow-mo.
Yeah, sorry, I really needed to slow-mo the section.
Things were just getting a bit too,
a bit too much for me.
Can I even jump up there?
I think I'm too small.
Oh my God, you can do a backflip.
Wait, do that again.
Oh, you're so talented, Blake.
What the heck?
Oh my, wait, wait, wait, wait, it's stunning.
No wonder he was a badass and was like,
nah, don't worry, guys, I got this.
You guys all run away? I've got this.
Okay, I can't actually reach that,
because I'm too small, which is fine.
Understand, what happened, I think.
Whee!
Money, hold on.
Money!
Okay.
I am going to prioritize health right now,
because we have...
In terms of health, we have none.
Although, wait, can I make something out of these?
I've got a star, star, two triangles.
Oh, I've got three triangles.
Okay, let's do three triangles.
Slow mo, no double jump.
Oh, there's double jump as well, what the...
Man, for a Neckle, you sure are agile.
Okay, we've got one thing.
You've got a fast forward, I assume.
Use fast forward to make time flow rapidly forward
and shave time off the clock.
When you use FF, it also gives immunity.
Okay, that's curious.
Right, we are going to go for hearts.
Uh, what's going on over here?
Okay, bit of water, yeah.
Bit of a water mission, yeah.
Right, you done four.
Nice knowing you, haven't I, say?
I hear someone bouncing.
Oh, I keep sorry, I keep doing that, but...
Isn't the whole point of Neckles and cats as they're agile?
Right, we're going in the sewers.
Ah!
See, I like old games, because their secrets are like,
go down this non-obscure path that's really obvious.
I'm like, thank you, that helps.
That actually makes...
Wait, am I going to get nuked?
I see him, is he about to throw stuff at me?
Sorry, Mr. Frog, your time is up.
Oh!
Hold on, the camera angle is killing me right now.
Oh, he's locked onto me!
No, no, he's eating things, I'm giving him!
Is he chasing me?
Oh, I love older games.
I love older games.
I love it, I really do.
I love when they don't look at me.
Right, so we're going up there, clearly at one point as well.
Oh!
I spoke too soon!
I spoke too soon, can I hit him in the back?
I'm going to have to, you're out of bounds!
Okay, I was going to say, you're literally out of bounds.
How am I supposed to do anything?
Right, let's pick up the bomb.
Watch the stream in 360 for the true experience, that's so good.
Let's get a heart.
Let's pick up some more things.
I need a dollar, I don't know.
I need...
Okay, I can't believe we went to Italy together.
Okay.
Oh, did I use furniture to get up?
Oh my god, the camera, please, you're killing me.
Okay, okay, okay.
My brain is expanding, I can use furniture to get up.
I understand, I understand.
I'm going to go out on a limb here and say,
I'm going to have to throw away these hearts in order to get across this bridge.
Oh wait, I almost messed that up there, not going to lie,
I almost messed that up there, but it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Right, we've got to rewind.
X to suck, B to select.
We're getting there and then rewind time so I can get the bridge.
Okay, then go across and then wallop him.
And then wallop him with a fucking bomb, apparently.
Look, that didn't happen and you can't prove it.
Wait, it re-winded the enemies back.
Right, fuck you, bomb.
I need to run away from the bomb unironically.
Did I get him?
Oh, I can have a heart, oh thank gosh.
Unfortunately my voice is still mildly strange, yeah.
I'm pretty sure if I wallop him, he'll come out with gold or something as a reward.
Okay, we have another heart.
It's weird because I think I saw you bomb yourself.
No, no, self-inflicted silliness proof.
Right, whose door is opening?
What was that?
Do that again.
He's really trying to get us to work.
I guess we go down here.
Okay, right, you, go on.
Okay, he has two health.
Okay, they're getting a bit more, giving a bit more HP but I'm needing a bit more HP too.
You can't have all the HP.
You can't have all of it.
I'm gonna do the star thing because I think we're gonna need it.
You go a slow, I'll take it.
What are you calling me?
TV.
I like how it's like all junk and stuff.
It's actually pretty creepy.
I'm gonna try and get another heart.
So we're gonna leave that behind.
Oh wait, no, it's the end of the level.
Yeah, we killed all the enemies.
Top right, old tails.
I'm gonna suck.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my.
Right, now we can buy another heart container.
Oh my gosh.
Now I don't want to get too cocky.
No, I don't want to get too cocky.
But hold on a minute.
I think we may, we may have a chance.
It's just a conspiracy.
I think we may have a chance.
We may have a chance to win him.
Oh, wait, there's 10 levels?
If there's only 10 levels in this game, we won.
I'm calling it now, we actually won.
I actually don't get sun logged.
Right.
A retry holder for 1000.
Thank you.
This lets you collect and use another retry.
Absolute.
Wait the game.
Okay, wait what?
It's on order?
What do you mean it's on order?
Okay.
And then what?
Pay.
Oh.
Okay, you have to like be rang up apparently.
Okay, we now have four health.
Can I exit please?
Jeez.
We now have four health.
And like total.
The difficulty still save one star.
You're making it.
There's nine monsters in this one.
I thought it was a microtransaction.
Real.
Okay.
We now have four health.
I don't know how big our health can go,
but I'm definitely wanting to put all the stonks
into having as much health as possible.
Because as there's more monsters in the game,
difficulty increases.
Yeah, I definitely did not get this far as a child.
I'm not even kidding.
I don't recall any of this.
Okay.
Which is such a shame.
I must have tried so hard.
My dad must have had to listen to it.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Well, I guess that's your problem now.
Oh, I keep, sorry.
I keep hitting B, please forgive.
I'm dumb.
Well, there's something up here.
Stop camera, please.
Why are you inverted?
Hello.
What?
I literally fucking cheated.
I literally just cheated.
You're fucking
staying.
Honestly.
Right, you died.
Yeah.
Okay.
Literally just spawned right in front of me.
What cheeky we saw.
Honestly.
I didn't know games had respawn like that.
I thought it was just if the enemy was gone,
the game accepted your fate.
We're only on one health.
This is not looking good, right?
B, reverse,
and then run across and hit the button.
Okay.
And hit the button.
Oh, I saw it up there.
I see it.
How am I supposed to climb all the way up there?
You've already beaten record.
Pretty much it.
This is a dub, okay?
Right, I seem to have opened some sort of location.
Oh,
I was right here.
Okay.
Okay, that auto lock.
I have to admit
that auto lock, gorgeous.
Whoever came up with that
stunning
and deserves a kiss on the lips.
Oh wait, I actually don't want to
fast forward, you know that.
I'll take a, I'll take a slow.
Slow is good.
Something
is going whack, whack over there.
Is it friendly?
Well, it's easy, so it's not that bad.
It's all about boundaries and targets.
Setting your new personal best, exactly.
Oh, not enough power.
Oh, okay.
The game is
insinuating I should probably have a better
sucker at this point.
I spent it all on health though.
Right, what happens in Vienna
stays in Vienna.
There's like a secret gamble machine
in this game.
I see the money on the bridge.
Right, what's going on down here?
I seem to have a rewind again
offered to me.
Wait, something's happening.
Oh, is it just a bridge in general?
Am I supposed to rewind?
Oh, no, you can go in war. It's fine.
It must be for the bridge above.
I don't know, maybe it did something.
Oh, sugar.
Hold on, wait, mate, hold on, wait.
I can't get up the ramp, mate, hold on.
You'll need to, you'll need to hold on, mate.
I can't get up the ramp. I can't.
Right, hold on.
Before you beat me up, let me...
He is coming.
Can he drown? Please drown.
I know he's an amphibian, okay?
I can even get up on that platform.
How's that?
He can't get on the platform either.
Did something break?
I think I'm supposed to reverse.
I don't know what's going to happen if I reverse, but...
Oh, one of the boats broke.
Right, hold on.
I don't know what I'm reversing right now, but...
No?
Oh, he never even...
He never even spawned in at this point!
Did I just need to run?
Fuck it.
Oh!
This is what I mean!
Fucking eat that bomb, you bam!
I mean, she...
Well, we're here, mate, I'll take it.
Okay.
We have two rewinds now.
It's very neat, please.
It gets pretty tough past the halfway point.
Don't say such things!
Oh, is this what I needed to rewind for?
Okay, no, I can just walk around.
Okay, that's fine.
Right, what are we doing here a little bit?
Oh my god, camera, please, I'm begging.
Oh!
Do not gamble, kids.
What the heck?
Do not gamble.
Don't come.
Literally, what the fuck?
You know, the normal, like, penalty
for, you know, losing to an...
Oh my god, camera, please, I'm begging.
Why is it reversed?
I'm on my hands and knees!
Why were the games obsessed
with reverse camera angle back then?
He's hitting the gritty on the button.
Sorry.
Please, right, okay, there's a bit of gold over here,
which we're going to need
for where we're going.
I think I might need a better, like, sucker...
I can't see.
I hear someone else.
Okay, you take two, which is fine.
Give him a second, let him get up, let him get up.
Let him get up. Go.
Okay.
We're doing it!
Let's go gambling.
Aw, dang it.
Let's open up a VTuber agency.
And it's like, art is going past deadlines.
You've been very specific on...
Oh, you can't finish...
I didn't know that!
I don't know if you've not perished everyone.
Oh, my goodness.
Is there, like, a secret we can access from up here?
I looked like the...
This one?
I mean, this one looks pretty straightforward.
And by straightforward, I mean,
just move straightforward.
Okay, we did it!
We got a secret cap metal.
It's as simple as just walking over to it.
Love me games when they're simple like that.
Mandatory...
Literally,
you have to, like, perish everyone in the area?
Clear time, 6 minutes.
Rank D!
Who the fuck is doing this in, like, under 3 minutes?
It's gonna be so f...
There's, like, freaking so many things as well.
We made 300 bucks.
Oh, the ball is worth 100 G.
It looks like we can also get
5 more ammo slots.
Oh, my God, we might actually get the red ones.
I'm just so good at this game.
Let's open an agency.
Three times the work.
No sleep. Ah, dang it.
I have to worry about the others.
Ah, dang it.
I have to make sure that everyone's happy.
So they'll sign on next year.
Ah, dang it.
Literally.
Can't sleep for 8 hours anymore.
Ah, dang it.
Okay, there must be a secret back here.
No!
Oh, my God, it's the forbidden...
Oh, look at the detail in this game.
He's like,
I'm about to fall over.
I sure hope I don't need a rescuing.
Can't really watch, but have a great stream to join me.
Thank you, Reefling.
I hope you have fun with what you're doing.
Right, I have full...
I have one slowdown
and two reverse.
Reverse. Reverse. Reverse.
Right, we must perish all enemies.
You are an enemy of the state.
You will perish.
Oh, well, I guess we're picking up that gem.
Actually, I don't know what the green circle does.
I don't think it's paws.
What does the green circle do?
It's very specific.
Okay, I think we might need
the bigger vacuum.
There's like, so...
those 16 ton things
are getting pretty...
That's what I'm supposed to hit.
Okay, okay, new mechanic
need to hit the thing.
How's the game going?
It's a good game, but I'm getting worried.
That's all I'm saying. I'm getting a bit worried.
Getting a bit worried that I'm not going to
be able to do it.
Getting a bit scared.
It's a bit scary.
Right, we're going to try and go for hearts
very carefully.
I just wasted those hearts.
That's rather frustrating.
I have to admit, that's rather frustrating
that those hearts get wasted
because I kinda need more health, but that's okay.
Right, who is here?
Okay, I have a door behind me.
So...
Oh, no, it's a bridge.
Okay.
Okay, you first.
You first.
You next.
Oh my god, I'm just...
Just...
Put me in, coach. Put me in.
I don't know why you have others on the map.
Put me in. I am that cat.
Okay?
I am that cat.
Motherfucker.
Because...
I don't know who you think I'm not.
Ooh, enemy over there.
And there's something under the bridge. I'm guessing.
I'm guessing.
Can we do this?
Let's do this one.
Hit him with the... Oh shit, wait.
Why am I slow?
Oh dear.
Oh dear. I wasn't supposed to be this slow.
When does it finish? It finishes right now.
Oh dear, right? Well, I'm getting kablamo'd.
Oh wait, they don't hurt me like that.
Aw, freaking sick. I just did all of that for nothing.
No, no, no, no, no, no. Not a fight right now.
I'm not ready. I'm genuinely not ready
for a fight right now. Please.
Okay, you.
Stop, stop. You're panicking me.
There's also an enemy over there.
Ah!
What was... What am I to do?
Right, he's away. That's fine. It doesn't matter.
Jeez.
This game is so stressful.
Right, do that. That's fine. Two monsters to go.
What's this?
What do you do? Oh, you're a fast forward.
Oh, no, you're not.
Because these are money. Money.
Money. Oh, it's the heart.
That's fine.
Okay, give me the heart.
Give me the heart.
And then, if we get all hearts,
I get two extra lives. Surely that's how it works.
Okay.
The gamble machine.
I'm not ready.
Absolutely blur it.
It's down here.
Is this a secret?
It looks like it.
Hmm. I don't know.
Maybe it's just a weird design detail.
Okay, let's get some more ammo.
You should go gambling.
I will pop on Balatruel right now.
Don't think I won't.
Right, let's pick this up.
And then, let's get ready to run away from the bombs.
I can't believe they were teaching us that
Gamba... Oh!
I can't believe they were teaching us
that Gamba are real bad.
Okay, what do we want?
We can only really meet
stars. It's always stars.
There's two more enemies.
Enemies. Gotta let it in the mood.
I get two more reverses.
Reverse. Reverse.
Oh, I can do a pause, right? Let's do a pause.
Shit.
Okay, I hate this game.
Been so dramatic!
What? I'm supposed to...
Oh, wait. Can I make another heart? Am I dumb?
No, there's only two there.
Every addiction story.
Let's get a success. Oh, dang it.
I had a really rough Balatruel.
I had it really rough
the last time we played Balatruel.
Sorry, I keep doing that. Stop pressing B.
You understand?
Stop it. Keep your finger off B.
No, don't do it.
One more monster to go.
Okay.
But where is it?
Down in the sewers.
Every addiction
starts somewhere.
Somewhere else starts.
Wait.
I just went the wrong way.
Wait, no. This opened up.
Who am I missing?
So this was a doorway to get up to here.
Okay, copium.
And where did I go from here?
Where did I go?
Did I miss?
Uh, brain?
Brain?
99 gamers quit before they make a big stop.
We're going to be encouraging people.
Oh, okay. There was a little path.
Okay, okay.
We're doing it. We're doing it.
Okay, where is this enemy?
There you are, ya bam.
Oh, I missed. There you are, ya bam.
No, don't suck it in.
No. Take the bomb.
Give him the bomb.
Hurry to the gold gate.
Yeah, what happens if I don't?
Okay, we get money.
Can we access
anything here?
I don't want to jump down
and go all the way around again.
Oh, there was money over there.
The point that the monster fell in the water.
Oh no, it respawned in front of me.
How much? 500?
200?
No, give me all the money.
I got 700 for that.
That's not bad. That's not bad.
Okay, we're doing the boss fight.
We're doing the boss fight.
I'm sure this will be easy.
The music is very funky.
It is very funky.
I definitely would like more ammo, I think.
I'm getting nervous.
Is there anything special behind me?
No.
Okay, boss time.
Copium.
Copium, boss time.
Okay.
Analysing.
Okay, he eats what I get.
I just made him so much bigger.
Right, how do I hit you?
Let us observe the attack pattern
of the enemy.
Okay, I've just made him bigger.
Oh my god!
This is literally an inflation game.
I don't...
How do I attack him?
How do I hit him in the back?
It is not possible.
How do I...
Yeah, he's so quick.
I don't...
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to let him charge me again.
But I'm going to be so brave
and let him charge me.
No, you need to do the stinky charge effect.
Hold on.
No, you need to do the charge.
Do the charge.
I'm going to stand my ground and wallop him.
Bruh.
Do I need to be right next to him?
Yeah, this.
Yeah, I think that's when I'm supposed to get him.
No?
Keep making him bigger till he blows up.
I don't know, maybe pause.
I don't have pause.
I don't have anything. I have rewind.
But that's like useless.
The entire map is going to be filled with...
Right, so he's going to jump.
Right, well, I think
it's when he jumps.
I think.
I think, I think, I think. I think it's when he jumps.
Okay, I think it's when he jumps.
He needs to do the gas attack
and then I basically need to stand my ground.
I think he locks on to wherever
he starts the gas attack.
So I can turn around
and hit him.
I just need him to do the gas attack
when I'm ready for him.
Okay, okay, okay.
No.
Okay.
Maybe not quite
how I was hoping for that to go.
Can you suck up the stuff he shoots?
Yeah.
That's what my ammo is.
He's given me ammo to hurt him, but...
Uh, I didn't work.
Probably need the crystals in the middle.
I can't make anything with the crystals.
I need a combination.
I don't have combination.
Right, no.
That wasn't it?
What?
How is that not it?
Oh, Reflanks.
Can someone look up Blinks Walkthrough Tutorial
Second Boss
and deja vu
location name.
I don't know what the heck I'm supposed to do.
I can't figure it out. Look, he jumps
and then he turns around to instantly
eat what I'm going to give him.
Oh, I just picked that up by accident.
Wait.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm supposed to jump up here.
Oh, I can't.
I'm just wasting all my ammo and panicking.
Okay, that's fair.
Inflation. Maybe just need combination.
Do, do, no, go strategy.
Shoot stuff.
I don't know this game, but I suspect throw something
in his big, wide mouth.
What is it? Just blow him up
by making him eat?
Like, he's literally immune
when he jumps, so it can't be that.
It can only be
hit the back in size.
I can only hit his back.
So all he did, I literally
just got done twice in a row.
What happens if I fail a mission?
Oh, dear.
Oh, no. Don't hit him from the front.
He just eats it. Use the pause
to hit him from the side.
Does he, like, give...
I don't have a pause.
I only have Rewind.
I'm not really sure how I'm supposed
to utilize Rewind. I'm going to be on it.
I don't...
Am I supposed to go into that fight?
Like...
But if I lose all my progress...
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. That's what I thought.
Hold on besties.
For no particular reason...
For no particular reason
I am going to just
type something in a YouTube...
No, whoa.
Your accusations?
No.
Your accusations? I don't know what you're thinking
that I'm doing right now in the background.
I've not got clues. Seriously, I've not...
Well, you hear something
in the back. No, you don't.
No, you don't. You don't hear a thing
in the background right now.
Hold on.
I don't know what you hear in the background,
but it's not
what you think it is.
It's not what you think it is.
Uh...
I'm just thinking, yeah, there's audio issues,
like, things are... Oh my god, that guy
has collected so many things.
Okay.
Right, for no reason,
you can hear the same boss music
but sped up in the background.
That's perfectly natural.
Uh-huh.
Okay, he doesn't have a pause on him.
Is that simple?
Right, so, you know the term
making a mountain out of a mole hill?
May
or may not.
This is... There's nothing stopping
you better try to click. Everything on the map.
I don't know.
I don't... There's not many games
that inspire me to go... Right.
Okay, now, if this doesn't work
after I've just done that, I'm going to be embarrassed.
But...
the guy basically did this. He went up to...
Okay, he went up to...
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Oh, piss.
Bro, how is this guy so good?
Right.
I'm gonna please leave him alone.
Can he come up here? Okay, is this respite?
Alright, I'll take it.
Hold X for item.
Okay, five ammo again.
Uh, right, okay.
How does that guy do it so good though?
Yeah, two of us can jump, bitch.
Oh, fuck's sake, hold on.
Oh, shit, I'm still in game.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
How did he do that?
Don't, don't judge me!
You can stay on the platform and just shoot
when he shows his back. Wait, real stress?
In 4k?
How did he go around?
He literally entered... Right.
Not that I'm looking at someone playing the game right now.
But if I was,
in theory, the guy literally
enters the arena, goes to the left,
the monster looks away
and he gets him in the arse.
But if I do that, he eats it.
Oh, he goes and gets a pause.
Alright, okay, maybe.
Oh my god, stop, I'm gonna die.
Again!
Stop, I'm embarrassed, I'm actually embarrassed.
I can't believe I'm cheatsy doodling.
Stop, I need a freakin' pause.
And not of...
Right, you, yeah, bam.
Right, that was my opportunity.
I'm like, 90% sure that was my opportunity.
Right, okay. Okay, boom, no.
Yeah.
Okay, it's stopped locked by a child game.
Fuck you, bitch.
No, that was my fucking chance.
Stop it, you're bullying me.
Hey, I told you you can bully children, you weirdo.
I'm literally,
I'm literally, this is who you're bullying.
I'm just a little hamster.
Alright, he went small again, I'll take it.
Oh my god, he's farting even more than usual.
Stop it, I'm just...
Stop eating everything I'm giving you.
Right, I need to go beat him up.
Right, come...
Yes, no!
Are you serious, you frickin'...
You frickin' frick...
You know exactly what you did.
No, I'm gonna miss.
No, that should have hit.
How am I supposed to play this?
Please.
Fuck, yeah, I'm aware.
I'm aware, I'm aware, I'm aware, I'm aware.
And he was immune.
And he was immune?
Of course he was immune.
I know I have no fucking ammo.
Oh my god, no, I can't do this, I can't do this.
Put me on combo, combo.
Put me on Halo Combat Evolved, come on.
Come on, put me on Halo, come on.
Don't do it, don't do it, don't do it!
Put me on Halo right now.
Put me on Legendary Halo.
I'll do that 10k challenge right now.
It'll be easier than this frickin' boss fight, I'm not even kidding.
Right, and then he's gonna turn around.
And then he's gonna keep going for me.
Right, hold on, I need to go on that platform
and pick up some ammo,
because I am out.
Now, don't you be...
Don't you be looking at me with your wee
wizardy things.
Yeah, you can jump me all you want,
but I'll be the one jumping you.
Oh, come on!
He turns around and does that all the time.
Is he big enough that he can shoot me from here?
This game is literally Dark Souls.
Okay.
You need to go small
before I can even fight you.
I have one health, I need him to barf out
and get smaller, because this is impossible.
I need him?
No.
You're just diving.
Your hitbox is massive,
and it's gonna hit me.
Not you. It's not gonna be a benefit.
I don't wanna go down and fight.
You're too big!
This game is Dark Souls,
but if it was actually hard.
Real and true!
Go small!
Okay.
I'm gonna balls it up,
but I'll balls it up.
Because...
And he's gonna turn around.
Yep.
And he's gonna come closer.
I don't know how I'm supposed to get yet,
so you're too big right now.
I literally cannot do anything about your
fricking size, and you'll do a big jump
and then I've not got time to do anything.
I'm gonna fucking...
Please stop billing!
No!
Please stop billing me!
I'm a literal child!
Oh, and then that was the perfect time
to probably wallop him.
And I missed it!
Stop!
How much can I give you up as a child?
But when I win, I'll be super happy, though.
But right now, I'm misery
and carny.
I'm carny now, I'm gonna fucking be happy.
No! Stop it!
Stop turning around!
Stop it!
Stop getting bigger!
I can't!
I suck so bad!
I'm literally sweating right now.
I'm so scared!
And I can't...
Oh, and maybe he goes tiny.
Stop sucking up things
that don't help links!
Suck up the ammo!
So we have a chance!
I literally can't do this.
I'm so scared!
I need one of you guys
to go on the fucking software
so you can go on my PC
and do this boss fight for me!
I can!
I'm actually gonna fucking suck lots!
It's only the second boss!
It's only the second boss
which makes us ten times worse.
I thought this was for we kids!
How did you eat that?
That was a 90 degree angle!
90 degree angle!
Oh my god!
I'm not gonna make it.
I'm actually not gonna make it.
I'm getting...
Okay, I regret.
I should have picked a better game choice.
I admit it, Reflin's okay. I'm the dumb one.
Please!
Please! AI, please!
I'm literally gonna perish.
There's so much furniture.
I literally cannot even do a circle around him.
There's like so much furniture
in the way to try and do this like circle thing.
Where I shoot him in the side!
Oh my god! Blink!
Blink!
Starlin!
Blinks! Why is it you auto lock
on literally everything else?
But the one time it was the perfect auto lock.
He goes,
mmm, is the enemy left,
right, fucking up my arse?
Blinks! Come on!
You knew exactly
what you were supposed to do.
Okay, let's try that again.
That was like our closest we have ever came.
Okay?
And he's so big, his hitbox is massive
and I can hardly do anything with it.
Okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay. Don't give up.
Don't give up.
Don't give him.
So I'll take him a little to the left.
Okay, I'm dead.
Oh my gosh!
Right, put me back in, chief. Put me back in.
Put me back in, chief.
Put me back in.
I'm not having this. I'm actually not having this.
I've been bullied about an old freaking game.
I'm literally sweating.
I have so much sweat on me right now.
And before anyone asks what colour of my pants are,
no, I'm not wearing any right now.
I can't marinate for three days
in the same underwear so I'm wearing nothing.
Okay, come on, come on.
We can do this, right?
And we already know
the game gives us a free pause, okay?
We already know the game gives us a free pause.
We are going to utilise it.
Okay, but first we're going to beat him up.
So he's going to do a weird thing here.
Nope, no he's not.
He didn't do it. I was expecting him to do it.
Okay, that's when he's going to do the thing
and he's going to hit us.
He used to like come to the wall.
What do you want from me?
What do you want from me? Seriously, seriously?
Do it. What do you want?
What do you want?
Is this game produced for children?
Because it's really
no giving me the impression
that a wane could do this.
No wonder I never got to the...
Go in! Go in the actual door as a favour.
Go in the actual door as a favour.
Die.
It...
You can't make this up.
He's invincible.
You can't make it up.
I wasted my pause on that.
Bruv, I'm actually getting...
And I missed.
Okay.
One, whoever the director
of this game is.
Your mum's a hoe.
Two, whoever designed this level.
Your dad wanks on all fours.
Free.
Whoever designed this particular boss.
You shag your cousin on the weekend.
I'm going to lose it.
I'm actually going to lose it.
I'm going to lose it. Everybody get to it.
Do it.
Let's see this frog is jumping.
The walls, he won't stop pumping.
You know, forever.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Let the hate flow through you.
Let the hate
flow through you.
Chancellor Palpatine.
Chancellor...
I...
I call upon you Chancellor Palpatine.
Please.
Please, let the freaking
dark side flow through me.
Because what the...
Fuck.
It's 5 a.m.
Please.
Please just let me win.
It's first thing in the morning.
Oh my god.
Please, it's a child's game.
Please.
It's a child's
child's
game.
Why would you ask for friend
perfect mechanics
from 5 year olds?
Please.
He's so big I can't
navigate around the furniture.
Go
here.
No, don't jump.
Don't jump.
Stop it. I literally can't
get around to me so big.
Please.
Oh my god.
Don't...
I have zero chance.
I have zero chance of completing this game.
I am just telling you all now.
I have fucking zero chance.
There's no way.
And to add insult to
injury, you can't even keep the goal
that you get at the end.
Why?
Am I going mental?
This is for
wanes. This is for children
who have not even got
hand eye coordination yet.
What was that fate?
This is literally the first Dark Souls.
Thank you. I'm so sorry I had to hear that.
Bruh.
There's
no way in hell we're completing this game.
I am warning you
now.
It is not happening.
We're going to get stuck somewhere.
I don't know where. I'm looking ahead at this guy
playing this game.
There's apparently
eight levels.
We're entering level three
and I was stuck on
the motherfucking thing. Oh, it's the water level.
It's the water.
It's me. This is my house.
Oh.
And there's glowing mushrooms.
You're making me think of the water.
Bruh.
Right.
I literally can't even see the enemies.
Okay. And then you're next.
Yabam. Right. Who's next?
Oh, he has extra health.
He's still alive.
Okay. Let's do that.
Get the juice.
Let's suck some things up
for some ammo.
This game may cause
a loss of sanity.
You know what?
I'm actually going to say
true and real.
Let's get some heart.
They never drop a heart when you want them to.
Oh, they did though.
No. Do not pick up another one or I'll cry.
I hear a lot bouncing off
ahead.
Oh, they're guarding
a little treasure chest.
No. Why?
Wait. Are there enemies
that pop out at me now?
One's a busty crust station.
And one's a crusty bust station.
There's something in here.
Oh.
Oh, my God. It's actually Dark Souls real.
Oh, stop. You're scaring me.
It's chasing me.
Stop it. Are you coded to come in here?
Be honest.
You're stuck at the coded doorway.
Damn right.
You're stuck at the doorway.
That's right. You better respawn back there, you little bitch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay. I love games.
Do more of that, please.
This makes me happy.
Wait. There's another boss identical to it.
Please don't say such
things. I'm just going to pretend
I didn't read that and you're actually just trolling
and there isn't a boss that's identical to that
frog and they didn't
do that to me because
why would you do that to me?
I can't suck up that chest to take...
Oh!
See this game.
See this game when it like picks up crystals
if anyone's hit them.
Please read all over me.
Honestly.
Bruh.
The wings...
Man, wasn't there not
somewhere else that I could explore back here as well?
Wait, it's all just frogs?
No, don't. I will literally
have nightmares tonight. Okay.
Wait, I can't progress to kill the enemies
on the other side?
Wait, did I need to go to the shop?
Can I not do this level?
I might not be able to do this
level.
If we can't
lift up that stuff from the shop.
Oh my god, we have a health.
A Christmas Markle.
Just wait till you get to the next block.
The tiers are going to be great. Stop!
Literally harder than Elden Ring.
You just despawned
out of nowhere. Oh, and...
Apparently we're not aim bottom now.
Lovely.
Oh, ah, okay.
Oh, I'm getting jumped. I'm getting jumped.
Blinks! Yeah, move on, buddy.
Yeah, move on. We need to pick up more ammo.
We're getting jumped. We're getting jumped!
Can they come down here?
I need more ammo.
I need more things.
Okay.
Pick up some of the ammo.
Okay, my health is full, so I actually
don't need...
There's another enemy here.
Okay, you keep glitching out
and it's making me nervous.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Right.
What?
A pause? I'll take a pause. I'm not going to lie.
I think pauses are really handy,
so I'll take the blue.
And then...
I still don't know what green does, but whatever it is.
I'll happy, happy. Dark Souls,
but with no rolling.
I'm getting into the cameras and buried.
Oh no, I don't...
I can't see underneath!
Goodness, gravy.
This game.
Okay.
Oh my god, I didn't realize that had
to come a bit closer to me.
Stop, please don't shoot me.
Okay, you go. You go!
Oh my god, wait.
These guys have two health.
They're green though. Green's supposed to be one shot.
Yellow's supposed to be...
Oh god, it's the frickin' bomb frog.
Where's the bomb?
If it's the last enemy, I'm just going to pause
and give him a big wallop right now.
One wallop for you.
And then where the heck is the bomb?
Where's the bomb? I'm running away.
I'm just hurting him and running away.
Excuse me, pardon me, coming through and you go find the bomb.
Okay.
Sugar.
There is no bomb.
You have to catch him off guard.
He's literally all locked to me though.
I don't see the bomb.
Did I walk past it? No, he's like locked onto me.
Oh, I'm just going to have to go back
and then...
Shoot him in the back basically.
Okay, that was lucky.
That was lucky, yeah.
Sorry, but that was.
That shouldn't have gone through.
Wait.
Was there a green back here?
There was, right, hold on.
Out of raw curiosity, I want to see what green makes
because I still don't know.
A record?
Oh, I can get the action shot.
Use record to record and play
back time.
A copy of yourself repeats what you did.
While you're being recorded, you're invincible.
What am I?
I can't even wrap my head around what on earth that means.
I've just got...
You're the bomb.
Hit Cider back.
Yeah, at least his hitbox was fair
unlike someone else's in this game.
Fucking hell.
I'm like so sweaty after that boss fight.
I'm so raging.
But we did it. Okay, we're on level 3.
Technically, we're about to be...
If we finish and get on to stage 4,
then we...
What do we do?
Reluctantly saying thank you for the tip.
Sorry, I was so angry I didn't even read it.
Enemy failed.
Literally enemy failed.
Record, do an attack, play it back
with a copy and repeat.
Okay.
See, the problem is I have to
actually hit the dying attack.
Haha.
I have to actually be...
Oh my god, look at the enemies!
How many is that?
14 in one level?
3.
Is this Legend of Zelda?
Oh no, you have to go through the waterfall.
Okay, I thought I was going to be like...
Oh, am I drowning?
I hope not.
Same box, 360 no scope.
Okay, there's loads of noises going on.
I don't like it, I can't see.
Okay, I can't see, I can't see.
I'll be the first to admit, I can't see.
Am I being attacked?
I don't know.
Okay, you're next.
Right, we'll do the pause.
I'm happy to do the... Oh wait, no.
I'm full.
Well, I hope it gets rid of the reverse
unless the stage like...
forces it.
If you know what I mean.
Ooh, we just got render spawn distance.
Did you see that?
That's how... Oh my god, it's a platformer!
Right, hold on, I'm picking up more ammo
because I'm going to get a couple ammoed in the air.
I can already see it now.
The game's going to be like, here's a billion enemies
in your face at once.
Some shorts can come out of this game.
I don't think so. This game is just misery
and suffering. I'm not sure...
I can produce a short that looks
like anything
remotely entertaining.
I'm sorry, but whenever I...
I just imagine, like, whenever I'm, like, raging.
That is just rubbish.
I don't care for money.
I care for not getting walloped
in a ram of enemies!
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
Okay, that's one.
That's two.
I'll survive.
Use Scream and Plea.
This is a child game.
Please let me win. It's 5am.
It's entertaining. Okay, is that it?
I have no idea what I say in the moment
when I rage. I just see red.
I see red. I see red. I see red.
It's just all...
So, you have no idea
how deep, how badly it goes inside.
Sadly, it goes inside.
What?
Okay, then we'll do the full ammo.
Technique, full ammo. Thank you.
Right, our health is full. We have a pause, a rewind
and a record for a double hit.
So, I don't really think
we necessarily have to do
anything right now.
We can do one more.
Can I aim for him?
I can!
Not him becoming
so flat in the sand.
That's so cute.
Still invincible.
Yeah, do a little power away.
You perish.
Genetically encoded rage.
Ancestral rage access.
Oh, I thought the game
just straight up kills you.
Okay.
How are you supposed to suck from over here?
I don't know.
Okay.
Uh, right.
We don't have full ammo,
but we do know
what kind of...
Is this a throw?
Okay, so two...
Oh, UV bastard, I see you.
Shit, I missed.
Yeah, use your magic somewhere else, UV band.
Camera angle.
Again, really not helping,
but I'll do what I can.
I don't see a bomb for the throw.
Okay, one of them.
If I could just
kind of perish the wee guys
in the ground first.
Eh, what a noise.
What a sound effect, honestly.
All right, pop out, pop out.
These platforms making the same sense
when you... Then you're strong, you audio...
Go, go, go, go.
Got one.
I really don't want to
mess up too badly.
No.
Come on, pop your head out.
Come on.
Come on, be a good enemy.
Be a good enemy, or is he only going to pop his head out
right next to the frog?
Come on, AI, lock onto me.
You know you want to...
Do you see a little neckl?
I don't want the frog to lock onto me,
however, because he becomes quite
a bit of a problem.
Scottish Rage ASMR win.
I mean, people seem to enjoy that meme
where it's like knocking you out ASMR.
If someone actually wants a parody,
I will happily make a parody
of me just like beating the shit out of the mic.
I'm pretty sure you're supposed to use
like a low quality mic as well
right. One in his arse.
Right, run away.
Run away, so the AI doesn't lock onto me.
Run away, run away.
Surely the AI
doesn't want any of this heat.
The AI wants some of this heat.
But once he realizes
he can't come up the stairs,
he will go away and I can shoot him in the arse.
Okay?
Okay, you can't find me.
No. Keep looking.
Yeah.
Turn around.
Every now and then.
Yes!
Okay, that was perfect.
See, the actual,
like, the actual
level's fine.
I'm not having to like, break a sweat over them.
But the fucking
bams
that designed that boss fight,
you know who you are
and you should be embarrassed.
Who flipped the label?
I love when you roll your arse.
Hit the mic at the end.
No, I thought like the whole point of like the rage
ASMR stuff is like, you batter the
crap out of the mic as you're like,
go to sleep.
Go to sleep. No, I've had enough of you.
I've been, I've been, I've been washing
your clothes every day. Your clays.
I've been washing your clays every day for you.
You leave stuff everywhere behind you.
I'm no your nanny. I'm no your mom.
I'm your partner.
I just start beating you up.
Go to sleep because you didn't make any rubbish
around the house when
when you're asleep.
Basically, that's how I imagine
how I'd make that ASMR. It's like
partner beats you unconscious.
He's
Scottish partner.
A C plus.
Oh, stop it, game. You're so nice to me.
G willikers.
You're so nice.
I don't know.
The way the boss is the easiest in the
game, I think the next one will have fun.
Don't say that.
Just sounds like you made half of the ASMR
concept on the spot. I do be kind of like that.
Right. What's going on with the shop?
What's our monies?
I've got
a thousand
a larger sweeper pack.
So that gives me more ammo.
Um,
at this point in time,
I think
I'm all good.
I just straight up buy bombs.
What kind of shop
is this, madame?
Okay, we now have
six items.
Instead of
five.
Anyway, we can put our ammo. I'm going to very
fill up. I'm going to very fill up.
I'm going to very quickly fill up
my glass with more water.
I kid you not, I'm like burst out in a
sweat in that fight of that region.
I'd literally just be a militant.
Don't worry.
Yeah, no one better thrown up
by, I was gone for
not even 10 seconds. I don't want any
throw up.
No, I was literally a militant.
I didn't even need a mic.
Thank you.
You have a British accent.
I've never been more insulted
in my life. May all your ancestors
be embarrassed on your behalf.
Right, okay, let's see.
What are we looking at? Right, so I
can have six items, right? Surely.
Yes, I can.
Okay, I think that was a good
investment.
I was in eternity.
I was gone for a millisecond.
Wait, what's going on with that chart?
Wait, if I'm not 10 items?
No, I can't even have.
You've packed them in a bit tightly game
after I'd met. This is a bit tight.
Like my
yeah, he is very close.
I don't know when the AI can lock on to me
but I'm getting nervous, okay?
He is staring. He knows I'm here.
I'm getting nervous because he has magic
that he can like Kablamo.
Yeah, that is what I don't want. Oh, he's a one
shot. Come on.
There's a lot going on in this area
after I've met. There's a lot going on.
I can hear.
I'm full health, so
wait, can I have 10?
I can have
seven? Wait, that upgrade
isn't. Oh, what does that mean?
Sorry, I've never not
killed one of them. Wait, I can have
10 items or something now?
No, Blinks, please
stop. You're absolutely
I don't know.
I can hear noises. I'm getting scared.
I can hear noises.
I don't know where the enemy is.
I don't know where the enemy is. I'm getting scared. Okay.
Wait, so if I mess up, I need to like
go all the way back here.
Right, no. I go here. I go
a little to the left. No, to be
confused with the hit video game. A little
to the left. Wait, I wasn't even supposed to go here.
Where am I supposed to
go? Hold on. Hold on. Let me
kick. I don't know. I'm supposed to go there,
but there's like a thing up there as well.
I don't know.
Hold on. Oh, and
I missed. And I missed.
Huh?
Oh!
Okay, I can't get it. I can't get it.
I'll just let it happen.
I'm not fighting. I'm not fighting.
Oh my god, there's spikes back there.
Okay, definitely do not go to ESK.
Okay, hydration check. We fit a little
to the left. We can't...
I know I probably should have
paused and grabbed it,
but I'm not that fast
right now.
I honestly, all I'm going to see
is it's going to be a...
Oh, no.
I don't know.
I'm just a wee
knuckle.
You're joking, right?
I...
Wouldn't it be funny if I...
Wouldn't it be funny
if I was completely stuck in the...
Okay, I'm fine.
I don't know what you're worried about.
Honestly, refland is fine.
Right.
I'm not even going to bother to pick up
literally anything because...
Okay, what was I supposed to do here?
Please be honest.
Right, okay. Let's get a POV.
Okay.
Follow the gold.
And I missed again. Are you serious?
Are you serious? Come on!
I'm going to stick. I have to go down again.
Okay. It's fine.
It's fine. I'm not mad.
I'm not mad.
Who said play this game?
Honestly, let me... Oh, it's going to be like a cute
little childhood game.
Yeah, no wonder I couldn't get past the setting level.
So I was for development team.
I didn't care what you were smoking that day when you were like,
you know what, let's... What?
Am I going crazy? Am I going crazy?
Am I going crazy?
I'm not sure what the game
wants from me,
I'm kind of just trying
to do some
things
over the rainbow.
I'll be
hopping away from...
Wait, there's a platform there!
I just spotted the platform!
Come on, planks! Come on, planks!
Come on, planks!
Oh my god, I just spotted the platform. I genuinely didn't see that platform. I'm not I'm not even kidding
I didn't see it. I've been jumping for ages trying to do something
So I can have 10. I oh my god. Look at the ammo upgrade
Oh my god, I didn't have to freaking try and do the world's biggest like bubble jump right you
Okay, let's let's get to it. I'm not mad translates to I'm raging and strongy
You know, it does make me region though, you know, it does make me region though when I'm wasting my ammo
Okay, oh, oh, oh, no. Oh, no, don't do that
Don't do that darling. Don't be so fucking stupid jump off the platform. Seriously
Oh
Okay, aimbot it's fine. I didn't want it anyway. It's fine. I didn't want aim assist anyway
I didn't I honestly didn't want it. I don't know what makes you think that I want aim assist in a game like this
That requires insane platforming like
I don't I don't know
please
Okay
Dodged it like a pro actually
Okay, there's only only a billion enemies ahead. It's fine
I
Know that one you okay
And suck that up
suck it
Oh, no, and I forget invincibility
okay
And then you're next
And then you're next and then you're next
And then you're gonna get up and then you're next
And then suck up these items. Oh my god. I'm doing it actually I should have got that upgrade a long time ago
It's a lot easier to
I don't want to actually I'm like I know it sounds silly, but I don't I'd rather have a reverse a pause and a double attack
Than anything else. Oh my god
I don't I don't know what you do. What do you do? I'm getting nervous. What do you do?
Oh
Are you serious?
Yeah, damn right
Damn freaking straight as if he like how is that supposed to know he was gonna trojan charge right in front of me like fuck off
How is that supposed to even like
Honestly
I lost like all my items. I have like nothing to my name now. Wait, what was that?
That's just a door. So then what was that button up there?
I've got an echo me. I've got an echo. I'm just here for a good time. He takes all the money
So he's stinky
No, I do not want to replace my everything with fucking one random thing. Sorry. I'm purposely doing bad combos
Uh, I'm guessing I could maybe get an upgrade that lets me hold more things
If so, that would definitely be a good upgrade and then maybe we'll go back to health
Two doors two buttons only one blink in need of the power of two
Oh, is this where I'm finally having to use record
Okay, bravo
record
jump
Then what just remain on it or go to the other one. I don't I actually don't know
I honestly don't know wait, what I don't know. I don't know. I've never used it before
What is the moon? Oh
Okay, okay. Okay. I'm doing it. I'm doing it. Okay. Thank god. I was smart enough to stay on standing on that button
Like actually, what does that mean? No blanks blanks. Wait blanks. What?
Wait, what?
Is that why it gave me so many green
Did I just sophomore Danny go back?
Oh, don't make me restart the mission
Don't make me go don't make me lose pro. No
No
Oh, wait. No, I have three green. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. Right
You jumped in and out of the button. No, just take the other gym. No hope. Okay, right
So what the game wants me to do
Okay
Is it wants me to record me on the button, right? And I just stay on it, right?
The entire time I stay on the button
Yeah
That's what I'm supposed to do and then I go to the other button and then I run
Okay
And then and then I do that I'm bouncing I'm bouncing I'm bouncing I'm bouncing I'm bouncing I'm bouncing I'm bouncing I'm bouncing
I'm bouncing, I'm bouncing, I'm bouncing
And then
Okay, okay
Okay
And then fucking son of
Fuck it. Wait, can I pause time? Maybe it's better to pause time. I have no idea
Oh, no, you can't pause time when there's time. Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, you need to fucking do. What? I don't understand.
No, what? I don't. What do you want me to do?
I can only have one in effect at a time.
Oh, for fuck's sake, this game's too confusing.
No, what does it mean?
Okay, right.
Right, fucking send it!
Fuck off!
Do you know how long it took me to get here?
Perish, no.
Don't annoy me.
Don't upset me, and you fuck off as well, you ebam, and he's gonna respawn.
He's gonna respawn, right in front of me.
I already know it.
I swear if the game bugs out, because he decided to go on a journey off.
There's a fucking...
You can't be like, your time's up, but then the monster's not even here.
I'll piss.
I'm fucking trying!
Jump, oh my god.
No, just to add insult to injury.
You have to fucking speedrun the bloody missions as well.
This game didn't age well, okay, I said it.
This game, I didn't even know there was a freaking time limit, and of course the frog despawns just to really upset me.
Like, you don't upset me, I'm actually, I'm raging, I'm raging.
Who picked this game? It was me.
Why did you pick the game? I don't know, okay.
I just assumed it was one of those games where I couldn't play it as a child, because I was a child, but I can't even play it as an adult, so...
Right, let's see what the damage is to the sanity.
Right.
Okay, already dying. Okay, nay. Yep, mm-hmm.
Didn't really even get started! Didn't even get started!
Oh, that's me. Oh, okay, right, okay.
Don't you love it? I'm even fucking getting started, and I'm already did it.
I've not even been able to comprehend. Oh, okay.
Oh, that was such a good attempt. Lovely, lovely game.
Very well rendered and polished bosses.
Okay.
So, okay.
Mm-hmm.
Right, okay, but see, here's the thing. I need to pick up ammo before you attack me.
Because how am I supposed to shoot you if I don't have any fucking ammo in my body holder?
Right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
Right, mm-hmm.
Yep, okay.
Uh-huh.
Right, if you keep your cool, the game's actually easy-peasy, lame and squeezy.
I can't believe it. I can't believe you let your emotions get the better of you.
Wah!
Okay.
Let's get over that.
Uh-huh.
I don't know where it is. I only have one health. Oh, I missed it.
That's okay.
Oh, that's not okay though. Don't do that again.
It takes away the platforms?
Monkho!
Um, I'm gonna be honest.
I need you to stop taking away the platforms that are for my safety.
Oh, look at that!
Uh, how am I supposed to shoot him if I have like one place to stand to shoot him on?
I don't, I don't know what you want from me, buddy.
I don't know what you want from me.
I don't, is one HP in a dream right now?
I'm one HP in a, well, I'm technically two HP in a dream, but I don't,
I can't shoot you from here.
Oh my God, right. Okay.
That one was actually fair, unlike the frog.
Unlike the frog, this one was actually fair.
Can I please at least keep some of the gems so I can upgrade my equipment?
I'm great.
I would like to keep some of the gems to upgrade my equipment.
Okay, now for the next challenge.
Actually get out the level.
Okay, that one, mildly fair.
Mildly fair.
That was a C rank for doing it in under three minutes.
Get real.
Like, actually get real.
This game is not for children.
I don't know why.
Japan, I don't know what's your obsession with making like the most frustrating games ever.
Like, aren't you frustrated enough with like the work fucking culture over there?
Like, why is it all bombs?
What?
Why is it all bombs?
It's going to set off a chain fucking reaction.
What is going on over there?
I don't even have anything to shove at them, other than bombs.
What are we nuking?
It's the forgotten city.
That looks like something I can bomb.
Or is it just map design?
It's just map design.
I'm so excited though.
I can't even get out there.
I can't, hold on, don't lock on to me.
I'm not ready yet.
No, I said don't lock on to me, I'm not ready.
Stop.
Don't, you're making me nervous.
I need hearts, okay?
Okay, thank you, I need hearts.
Give me one.
Give me two.
Give me three.
Give me four.
Oh yeah, do I have another purple?
I do, right, we can technically have a rewind.
Why are you locked off the previous part of the map to me?
I was the one who got us here.
Right, we'll do a rewind.
Suck the ball and get a hundred easy smackery.
I probably should actually.
Everything's a freaking death trap.
In this map, honestly.
I just want items.
And it's like bombs.
I think I'm gonna run out of time at the rate I'm going at.
I'm not gonna lie, this is getting rough.
What's this?
There needs to be two of you to go higher on a sea soul.
Whoa.
You guys are bouncing away over there.
I don't know what you want from me.
I need the green over here.
I just want, I want two green.
I'm gonna so run out of time this map, I'm sorry.
There's no way in hell.
So Bravo record.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Okay.
I don't know if I need to...
Is that actually gonna kablamo me?
Hello?
I spent half an hour jumping on that.
And the game's like, yeah, nice try.
What?
Two, three.
The other way? It can't be.
Oh wait.
No, it can't be. Are you trolling me?
It can't be.
I'm supposed to go up the green path.
You've just trolled me and I need to restart the mission there.
Oh, right.
What am I supposed to do?
Oh no, it's gonna repeat.
Where do I go?
Can I go on an edge here?
Oh wait, there's an edge.
No!
Wait, is there anywhere I can go?
I don't think there's anywhere I can hide.
Run! Mummy's trying! Mummy's trying!
I'm trying to get out of the blast zone.
Oh my god, I did somehow.
Jeez.
I kind of purposely want him to start throwing shit at me.
Yeah, I'm gonna need some more stuff other than bombs to get anywhere.
I'm not even kidding because this is getting bad.
We have eight monsters to go.
I mean, we're hardly anywhere.
Oh my god, it's just all bombs.
This entire map is just bomb city.
I do appreciate the kind of...
I know you're getting...
But this is so dangerous.
I'm gonna pick up the pause and then I'm gonna pick up the heart.
I think we might be replaying this one.
I'm not even kidding.
This is just all bombs.
Only bomb.
There's something blue over there.
I just saw it.
It's something neon blue over there.
Okay, thank goodness we have a rewind.
I'm gonna be honest.
This game concept is starting to...
Hmm, oh well. No, it's fine.
You can just randomly throw the bomb not in the direction of anything.
It's fine. I didn't want to win anywhere.
That frog didn't die?
Do you eat bombs?
Bro, this guy can...
Oh yeah, I was gonna say, what's going on here?
You made me nervous.
I'm gonna be honest.
I'm gonna be...
This is the first game in almost two months that I've picked purely on.
I admit it.
Hello? Where are you?
Suck'em?
Huh?
Well, that was bloody creative.
I'll give you that, Dave team.
What was that?
There's sort of bombs in there.
Oh, well, I missed that one up.
I literally have four minutes left.
Are you serious?
Is the door evil? Why is the door evil?
Can I come in?
Oh, falling down.
Oh, balls up. I'm in the swamp now.
Ooh, maybe.
Do I all lock on you or what?
What do you do?
I don't...
Do I raid you like a fucking carpet?
Do I suck you up?
Let me in!
Huh?
That is...
Okay.
Suck'em up.
I don't know. Maybe suck'em?
Did he just suck...
What?
Oh, okay, well...
Pause his tea.
All doors are evil. Boldest things.
What?
He's trying to hurt me.
Someone says pause.
Is any like a bear vacuum?
I don't know.
There's literally nothing I can do right now.
Oh, other than bomb myself, apparently.
I don't...
I don't know what you want from me, buddy.
I'm afraid we've lost this one.
I'm due to team.
That I don't understand.
Can you jump on him while pause?
Ooh, like jump over the gate?
That might be it.
Jump around the door park or so.
I want to say yes, but I...
Oh!
Well, I've done it now.
I was joking!
I think we were joking!
I legitimately thought...
I think we were joking.
Oh, my God, please.
I don't have time for this.
I don't have time for like four back-to-back enemies
in a really close environment with bombs everywhere.
Oh, this is gravy.
Who should I go for him?
I need my...
Ray, okay.
Okay.
What is going on with the shop?
We're not making it out of this one, see?
I don't even have enough.
I have enough for another heart container.
That's the best I can do right now.
But we...
I'm warning everyone who's like,
oh, she's gonna finish the game this straight.
I am not.
I'm not.
I'm saying it now.
I think when Sheebie goes live,
we'll redirect into her,
because it's just no happening.
Pompey, more like shite pay,
because this is awful.
Lost city, more like shite city.
Thank you, I'll be here all week.
You're not.
There's no way.
I'm getting stuck in the child's game.
There's no way in heck that I'm doing anything remotely right.
Like...
You know what I mean?
I'm gonna finish the game twice.
I don't know if she'll be streamed.
She's having problems with the cat.
Oh, okay, okay.
Like, it's no happening.
Okay, we need to rewind.
That's fine.
If I can jump over this,
right, is there a heart?
There is.
We're gonna fill our heart container up.
You've got two.
We try.
Try using other projectiles
and just the bombs.
The bombs can't hit enemies properly.
Wow, it is not...
How do you say in French?
It is not possible.
No, it is not...
No, no, no.
It is...
I like how he's on the platform.
Okay.
Great.
Then we need the green.
Get green.
Get greened on.
Okay.
I guess we'll put the green.
I guess we'll take the two of these.
We've lost our pause,
but I don't think we needed one.
Okay.
Then Bravo.
Then A and a.
Jump.
I'm aware.
Okay.
That was like a billion jumps.
Right.
How did I survive this last time?
I think I got like frame lucky or something.
I don't know.
Feels a bit tight.
Not right next to me, you twat bag.
Jump the wall.
Cling the wall.
I think we're safe.
Okay.
I don't know how we did it,
but I think we're all right.
Okay.
I would like him to shoot Furniture,
but he's really refusing a lawful enemy.
Oh, he does it just as I perish him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That works too.
Pro strat is literally.
Ugh.
Okay.
We've got the door.
Is there any health we can mash together
or not?
We're really just going to look up.
Okay.
We're just going to send it.
We're going to need to scoop up some bounce.
Oh, and I'm just trying to.
Oh, wow.
That for someone who couldn't see the enemy,
that went a lot better than what could have happened.
Right.
So the bridge is going to get destroyed up ahead.
That's fine.
We're expecting it.
I'm going to grab a pause.
Uh.
Okay.
We're doing much better this time around.
Let's not give up just yet.
I've already gave up inside,
but let's not give up just yet.
Okay.
A 316 no scope literally around the corner.
Can you see the damn thing?
Um, is Emmy coming online?
Okay.
Hold on, Mr. Frog.
Not now.
Oh.
Nope.
That wasn't it.
Don't be afraid to turn around
and look at the enemy blinks.
It's Mercy instead.
Oh, don't make me play this game for six hours, guys.
Please.
Anyone pop up stream right now?
Oh, no.
The fucking enemy frog
that's getting closer with each hop.
The aim assist is gone.
It is non-existent.
Okay.
Let's go.
Got paused by accident.
Look at his face.
So happy.
Okay.
Does it...
Did it have to be paused to get around?
Whoa.
Wow.
Okay.
It unironically had to be paused.
Do you want to know why?
Because it is all locking on that ghost fuck...
Wait, I wasn't...
Wait.
Did I do a frame perfect thing
that I've never been going to be ever able to do again?
You have ASMR clubs to work on?
I would much rather go offline
and then I will upload...
Stop!
Right.
So you didn't auto lock
to literally any other enemy,
but when it comes to that ghost,
all of a sudden...
Ooh, we love auto locking.
Ooh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Up my arms.
I'd rather go offline
and then in exchange,
I will literally subtitle the shit
out of that fucking...
Um...
Prego ASMR for you.
And then I'll upload that instead
because...
Fucking hell!
Why do you take a pound in?
What are you, ectoplasm?
Oh, no.
My bombs, I need them.
But...
I've just done that now.
Fucking how much HP you got, bruv?
It's a bit outrageous, honestly.
Okay, he's like taking more damage.
And of course that hurt me.
Ooh.
That sounds like a good idea.
Yeah, I'd rather upload pregnancy ASMR
than finish this game.
But you have to give me credit.
For streaming for two months
in only one game,
I'm like, I'm fucking miserable playing.
You have to give me credit.
I've picked Will.
Sorry, I said it.
I'm sorry.
I'm giving myself a pat on the back.
I literally...
What are you?
Okay, please don't give me the ghost back though.
Okay, let's try this again.
Without this guy being a squat baggin...
Okay, well...
Oh, I'm getting...
Right, anyway, pregnancy ASMR, anyone?
Anyone want to be in my tummy?
Who would like to be in my stomach?
Because I know what it's one of yours.
I know what it's one of yours that want to be in my tummy.
Okay, now give me credit where credit is due.
I've streamed every single day.
I've done so much variety of games.
Please allow me to shove one game in the bin, okay?
Please, I ask you kindly,
allow me to put this game in the bin.
In exchange for putting this game in the bin,
I will upload pregnancy ASMR.
You have my word.
I have the energy to continue, okay?
I have the energy to keep editing.
I will upload that pregnancy ASMR as fast as I possibly can, okay?
You must continue.
Absolutely not.
I'm sure it's probably fun.
It might be a bit funny ha ha to watch me rage or whatever.
I am miserable and dead on the inside right now.
I may not sound it because I'm happy to upload the...
I'm happy to upload what?
I'm happy to upload the pregnancy ASMR, okay?
Does this mean this is the shortest stream I will ever do
for the rest of my streaming days?
That is how short the stream is, okay?
No need to...
Yeah, I'd rather not push it.
That's all good.
It's okay, mommy.
I really don't care about the game.
It's because I enjoy watching games.
Oh, that's adorable.
I will redirect into the only streamer live right now is Nene.
And she's doing the DLC.
So if you don't want any Elden Ring spoilers,
you are welcome to not watch that
because she is doing Elden Ring thingy.
And that is the only person I'm subscribed to
that's actually streaming right now.
So here we go.
Aw, she's doing that little 3D TV model.
Okay, I do apologize.
I did plan to stream longer,
but in exchange for me pissing off all,
I will upload the pregnancy ASMR, okay?
So get ready to be in my stomach
in probably T minus one hour.
I'm gonna make a cup of tea.
I'm gonna fucking subtitle out the wazoo.
And it will be up in an hour.
Okay, give me one hour.
And don't forget to hit that like and subscribe bell.
Come on, two months.
Two months and I've dropped one game.
Come on, you have to give it to, come on.
You have to give credit where credit's due.
Come on, streamed every single day.
And only dropped one game.
Come on, give it to me.
Come on.
I'll definitely research.
I normally always research the game I'm about to play.
This was the only exception
because I did endurance yesterday for 12 hours.
This is literally the exception, okay?
Thank you so, so much, my little reeflings.
I do apologize, but with the same gesture,
I do offer you straight up pregnancy tomorrow
as a sorry, which I think hopefully
repays the debt.
Tomorrow, I believe, is...
What is tomorrow?
Whatever tomorrow is, it's better than today.
I'm so sorry.
Tomorrow...
Oh, I've not even uploaded my schedule.
Do you guys know what I'm doing tomorrow?
What is my schedule?
Hold on, let me pull it up.
Oh, here we go.
Okay, let's just pretend today didn't happen.
It's ASMR and then a membership watch along.
Okay, nice and easy.
Cheeky ASMR, can I ask?
I'll actually do it.
And then I have back-to-back Lego Lord of the Rings,
which is my favorite game of all time.
So we're doing ASMR tomorrow,
and then we're doing watch along and membership.
If that's not your cup of tea, please don't worry.
I stream every day.
You'll always have free access to the stream every single day.
And then we're doing back-to-back Lego Lord of the Rings.
100% completion is my favorite game,
is one of the top 10 games of me personally.
I love it, I adore it.
Peggle doesn't need an introduction,
but pegging possibly.
I don't worry, I'll e-shoot into it.
That was disgusting behavior, but I love it.
And then a membership hand-cam ASMR.
I'm testing out a prop.
No, not a figurine.
Stop.
It's a prop for ASMR before anyone is like,
a prop?
No, relax.
I'm not trying to bait you into becoming a member.
Okay, relax.
I'm using a thing,
and I'm testing it with you guys
before we do a mainstream with it, okay?
No, it's not a figurine, okay?
It's not a figurine.
Then I'm doing a mystery,
Dead by Daylight collab.
And I think I know who the team's made up of,
so I might actually brush off on my Dead by Daylight very shortly.
I did the tutorial, but we like working.
Then we're gonna do public.
Public, that sounds rude.
It is gonna be Fortnite
as our StreamSnipe game.
I don't know how it's gonna go.
I've not played it in a very long time,
so again, I'm gonna have to do my research soon enough.
And then membership, we're going to try chess.com.
I need to make an account and all of that,
and then we're gonna see if we can stream snipe each other in chess.com.
And then Halo Combat Evolved,
which needs no introduction,
but please remember
that Legolord of the Ring starts two hours later
than my usual start time,
because I'm having the Veiler meeting.
That's when we're doing it.
Oh my god, oh my god, inside news.
That's when the meeting is conducted.
Because everyone's awake at that time.
And it's not too late for Icicle, poor Icicle.
If Gen 2, if we get Gen 2,
and there's more European members,
we're getting fucking fubbernocked.
But anyway,
Dead by Daylight is one hour before my usual start time.
Please be aware, okay?
But everything else in this week, perfect.
Nothing is gonna make me be reached.
This game, I'm sorry, I ain't cut out for this kind of game.
I'm sorry, I ain't built like that.
But yes, this is the plan, this is schedule.
And T-minus one hour, when I click go offline,
T-minus one hour, we will play.
We will, you will be in my stomach.
I will be pregnant with you.
We will have an umbilical cord together, okay?
Deal, deal.
Okay, I love you.
I love you, Reeflings.
Thank you for your patience.
Wait, you're also playing Fortnite?
That's the StreamSnipe game.
For a public StreamSnipe game,
we're gonna try and play Fortnite,
but I don't know if it's gonna work.
I ain't played Fortnite since that thing came out.
So I have no idea what to expect,
but I'm gonna do some offline play,
just so I know what I'm doing.
I'm not making a mockery of myself, right?
Okay, I love you, little Reeflings.
Okay, I do apologize, but at the same time,
pregnancy is smart, so you can't get mad, okay?
Now give me a kiss.
And as always, when I redirect into someone else,
please do be respectful of them,
because I am not them, they are not me.
Love you, Reeflings.
Thank you for your unwavering patience for me.
T-minus one hour for the prego ego ASMR, okay?
Mwah!
See you tomorrow, Goofy Goofy!